[Music]
I'm going to read a quote from one of
your exes if you think you know who that
applies to Bing that belt I hope that my
exes realize like how tan and happy I am
now I'm terrified of the results I think
I was okay guy I think it was okay guy
okay
I'm pretty nervous to play this game
because the host said that he had a
tough time tracking down my exes
I'm not nervous to talk about know about
with a good boyfriend so I'm not worried
one bit our relationship was like
finally having the worrisome
overprotective Jewish mother
I never wanted shallow Bethenny I'm
sorry Jessie that is not correct
nice work Gabi that was me the
overprotective Jewish mother being with
this person was like standing in the
shadow of a pharaoh
I think it's curly you'd be correct
I fell in love with this person the
first time they beat me up on the bus
I think curly was in on the buzzer early
on that one
what's your guests curly baby I think a
[Music]
just the personal space issues you have
here alone I can see translating to a
bus and it being a bit of yuzu this
person is fun talented smart and great
in the sack and most of all they loved
my mechanic smell girly you nailed it
are you this person will be totally
loyal unless it conflicts with their
interests at any given moment Jesse K I
like the most generous person ever I
like by takeout for my well I don't buy
takeout but I get the takeout what I'll
get to take but I enjoy the tea
unfortunately Gabby you are incorrect
Jessie V no offense that's a good thing
first tasting sometimes a louder I'm
sorry Jesse you are incorrect why I'm
gonna read it one more time this person
will be totally loyal unless it
conflicts with their interests at any
given moment
I'm gonna say Gabi you would be correct
I've always about me I thought it was
about me okay here's the thing girls
just have like the best life and like
everybody loves it so I would just like
to say that I contacted one of my
ex-boyfriends and asked him to be in
this video and I was like leaving this
video and he was like I'm not over you
and then like 22 seconds later we were
having he had sex in my apartment so
thanks a lot BuzzFeed I feel like that's
a good thing can you pay for my UTI
medication UTI medication for everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
have you gotten to our arms
[Music]